[Music]
there are some
would make me out to be
the villain
of this here story
[Music]
are you born with destiny
or does it just come
knocking at your door
these young singers from memphis
tennessee
give him a warm hayride welcome
[Music]
mr elvis wrestling
get a haircut
buttercup
in that moment
i watched that skinny boy transform
into a superhero
[Applause]
[Music]
he was my destiny
i wish to promote you mr presley
and the challenge
are you ready to fly i'm ready ready to
fly
tomorrow all of america will be talking
about
they might put me in jail for walking
across the street but you're a famous
white boy
what he's saying is god-given so there
can't be nothing wrong with it
senator kennedy
martin luther king has been shot to
death in memphis that's all right
tragedy but it has nothing to do with us
it has everything to do with us
[Music]
once told me when things are too
dangerous to say
[Music]
and how are yours
[Applause]
i just gotta be making the most of this
thing what i can
this could all be over the flash
[Music]
we are the same you and i
we are two odd lonely children reaching
for eternity
[Applause]
the greatest show on earth
elvis has left the building
[Music]
you